again
fishermen even more Divino has worked
most of his adult life here
[Applause]
four years ago we visited vergel dolaro
a shanty town on the shores of the Munda
Lagoon
day and night the men Dove for a tiny
muscle-like shellfish called surulu
while the women and children toiled to
extract the seafood inside they barely
eked out a living
[Applause]
but now even that's gone
ivanildo wants us to see that floods
earlier this year destroy the livelihood
of more than 1200 families
only shells They're All Dead there's
nothing here
lives in a tiny Shack with his wife and
two daughters
[Music]
there's a lot of hunger here yes hunger
a lot of hardships we can't make a
living anymore
the floods also destroyed many of the
Shacks
but only a few families have been
offered an apartment in a public housing
project that is swallowing up their
Shanty Town leaving many like Maria Rosa
Da Silva with nowhere to live
and we don't get anything nothing just
promises they review your file and if
you're old you don't get anything
the state and federal aid is irregular
and insufficient 15 years ago Brazil had
eradicated extreme poverty but six years
ago the situation began reverting and
now Brazil is back on the hunger map
according to Brazil's Institute on food
Security today more than 33 million
Brazilians are going hungry and nowhere
more so than here in the state of Alaska
in the absence of effective policies to
combat poverty and unemployment
malnutrition and hunger has more than
doubled and that is having a devastating
impact on the development of children
like these
academics point out that the last two
governments began reducing or
eliminating social programs long before
the pandemic
the existence of hunger is a political
decision hunger is caused by the
decision not to implement public
policies that could fight it there's
been a political decision to prioritize
other things
and in the absence of a plan to
eradicate extreme poverty where
zeldolargo residents have started to
breed food
a collective project to ward off hunger
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Marseille Brazil